informed consent stands for the rights
of patients
and is a key part of the clinical
research process
in this video we will review the process
of obtaining informed consent
and how to inform patients about being a
clinical trial subject
informed consent is the process through
which researchers provide the necessary
information to potential participants
so that a knowledgeable decision can be
made about whether the individuals wish
to take part in a research study
it is an ongoing process that begins
with initial recruitment of subjects
and continues after the initial oral or
written agreement form
from an individual to participate in a
research study
upon getting familiar with all the
information related to the clinical
trial
the patient has the option to decide
whether he or she wants to participate
in a study
if they agreed to do so an
administrative procedure is completed
and the patient becomes a clinical trial
subject
let's review the differences between
being a patient and being a subject
as we mentioned when a person volunteers
to participate in a research trial
his or her status changes from patient
to subject
a subject in a clinical trial is an
individual who participates in a
clinical trial either as a recipient of
the investigation of products or as a
control
the subjects may not be receiving
standard of care as patients do
the risks related with the treatment may
be higher
documentation for subjects is more
extensive than regular clinical
documentation
finally the subject is the ultimate
decision maker
and must have complete information to
assure his participation remains
voluntary
in general there are five steps in
obtaining an informed consent
step one of the process is introduction
the investigator must introduce himself
or herself to the potential subject
and the proposed study step two an
explanation
the investigator must explain the study
to the potential subject
providing all pertinent information such
as purpose procedures
risks benefits alternatives to
participation and etc
3 comprehension the potential subject
may be provided with a study information
sheet
and must be afforded sufficient time to
consider whether or not to participate
in the research
step 4 question and answer session after
allowing the potential subject time to
read the study information sheet
the investigator must answer any
additional questions the potential
subject may have
and may obtain verbal agreement to
participate in the research
and step five obtaining consent
the following video will demonstrate how
an informed consent can be taken
is it mrs celine yes hi i'm katie one of
the pivot teams okay if i talk to you
about your injury yeah
okay great so i understand you're
breaking your leg how did you do it and
i was out roller skating with my sister
actually and she just crashed into the
back of me and
sort of took me out and i fell quite
badly on on my leg my goodness
okay well i'm sorry in this position has
anyone actually come to speak to you
about this yet all the treatment options
that are available
um no not yet no okay so you've broken
your bone
the break is actually quite low down in
your leg near the ankle joint
and sometimes when bones break we can
hold those together with a plaster cast
and but in your instance where the bones
have moved apart you'll need surgery
unfortunately to put those bones back
together
okay now there are two different
treatment options available a nail or a
screw and plate fixation the nail will
be inserted down the middle of your bone
to hold the bones together
and with a screw and plate fixation the
plate would be put alongside the bone
and used to put the bones back together
and so both treatment options are good
treatment options and both are used
routinely throughout the uk by surgeons
fixing this type of injury
however we don't actually know which
treatment option if either is better for
the patient
in terms of pain and function in the
long term so we're actually running a
study in this hospital to hopefully
answer that question
so we've got some information about the
study would you be happy to read it
yeah no that'll be fine so here's the
information
and so it's quite a lot of information
to read so i'll leave you for a few
minutes and then i'll come back and see
if you've got any questions like okay
yeah that'd be all right
okay so how did you get on i'm all right
actually yeah it's
quite a lot of information to take in
yeah okay yeah
i appreciate you probably weren't
expecting to be in this situation either
so
have you got any questions for me yeah
actually from reading the information
sheet
i think um it sounds like the nail
fixation would actually be the one that
i prefer to have
done out with the two right okay well if
you took part in a study wouldn't
actually get to choose which treatment
option
that you would have we'd randomly
allocate you to receive either treatment
option
and that's purely so we can make it a
fair test between the two treatments
so you'd have a 50 50 chance of
receiving either the nail or the screw
and plate fixation is that okay
right it's just um i felt that the nail
fixation would
possibly be a little bit stronger and
help me get back on my feet quicker
because obviously want to get back to
work and pick up my skating again when i
can well unfortunately don't know which
treatment option would be quicker for
you to get back on your feet
and that's what we're trying to find out
those treatment options are good
treatment options but in the long term
we don't know which treatment option
will be better
and the rehabilitation will be exactly
the same with both treatment options
it's likely to be using crutches for up
to about three months after your injury
and then getting back to sort of roller
skating in your hobbies normally
six to 12 months post injury and that's
likely when
you'd be back on your feet and that'd be
the same for both treatment options
that are available okay um if i were to
take
part in this today would there be a lot
of appointments for me to come into the
hospital
or paperwork to complete anything that's
sort of going to take my time out
we do actually ask you some questions
throughout the study and that's purely
so that we can understand
how you the patient is recovering so we
ask you those at baseline how you wear
pre-injury
and then we ask you those again at four
of the time points um throughout the
study
so six weeks when you come in for your
normal routine checkup and then again at
6 and 12 months at 6 and 12 months
you'll be coming in for your routine
appointment with a consultant
or clinician anyway and we'd ask you
those questions at those appointments
but the time point in which you wouldn't
normally come into hospital is three
months so we'd send you that
questionnaire in the post
okay so the questionnaires would
probably take about 10 to 15 minutes to
complete
and would be happy to fill that in and
send it back in a free post envelope
that we would provide that'd be great
you know that sounds alright if you're
making use of the appointments when i'm
coming into the hospital anyway
yeah yeah um i think it's something that
i'd be quite happy to do actually the
the options seem fairly similar and i
don't think i'd mind which one i'd
receive and
okay i'm not taking good so much
different attention yeah no i think that
would be great
great okay well if you're happy to take
part in the study is that okay
yeah great we'll fill out the consent
form and then we'll go through and do
the questionnaire is that okay
yeah that'd be fine
you